and so one of the ways i sort of
visualize things was it's like you're
playing a
computer game you've got these four
indicators finances
skills relationships and health and then
your ability to deal with change
and what you've got to make sure is that
none of them are going in the red so
it's fine if you're focusing on money
right now as long as you think actually
when am i going to update my skills when
am i going to invest in my relationships
and so they're aware that there will
come a point where you have to flip
and similarly if you're just focusing on
skills like that's great you're building
up your skills but what about the other
things and that's why i think life has
got more complicated because
life over 70 years and a three-stage
life all those things were taken care of
just by following what everyone else did
that won't work anymore you have to do
things differently
i'm joined by andrew scott andrew
welcome to the show
nice to talk to you chris a pleasure to
be here lovely to have you here so we're
talking about getting older
kind of yeah
and i'm an old man at 55 although not an
old man at 55 that's one of the things
so
uh i work along the area of longevity
i'm an economist
and i kind of think society's got
something wrong because we keep talking
about this aging society
you know there's the birth rates
declining people are living for longer
there's more old people
which is certainly true i mean a number
of people aged over 65
is growing everywhere uh over 80 is
growing
the fastest growing age group the number
of people aged over 100
for the first time ever the world today
has more people aged over 65
and under five you kind of get the story
and the general problem is that scene is
a challenge because old people are a
problem they get ill
they don't work they claim a pension we
can't afford it
but actually i think we need to flip it
around and actually
look what's really happening which is on
average
we're living for longer and we're
healthier for longer so whatever age you
are you've got a lot more time
ahead of you and certainly the younger
you are the more time you have got ahead
of you so the
uk government in 2018 said one in five
girls would live born today would have
to be a hundred
one in five girls is going to be yeah
triple triple figures the queen's gonna
be knackered
right i mean the queen you apparently
used to have one person sending the
telegrams of 100 now she's got a
department of seven
um in japan they used to send out a
silver sake dish when you reached a
hundred they've scrapped it now because
they couldn't afford to do it because so
many people are reaching age 100.
um and that but the thing is we kind of
therefore
what that means is every one of every so
the average brit has never been
so old but never had so long left to
live
what an odd paradox yeah so kind of
you've got
more time ahead of you in a way you're
kind of younger not
older but you know what this is the way
i put it is as follows you've seen these
big increases in life expectancy but we
haven't changed our concepts of age
because we measure age by the number of
candles in your birthday cake
and of course 12 months is always 12
months but how we're aging is changing
we're actually aging
better so biological age and
chronological age are breaking out a
little bit their relationship and
if you look at the scientific research
happening they say wow you've got you
haven't seen anything yet some wild
things are going to happen
you know everyone's going to live to 120
and be healthy forever it's kind of what
some people are saying
but this is really about having more
time and what i always say is that you
know
if your day went from 24 hours to 32
hours
which is like life expensive getting
longer you'd run your day differently
i mean what would you do chris would you
get out of bed the same time and go to
sleep the same time what would you do
someone asked me what superpower would
you have if you could have one
and i said never need to sleep and
that's essentially the equivalent of
what you've just given me there
oh god if you gave me if you gave me
another eight hours
in my waking day it would be
it would be glorious but then
parkinson's law
right you expand your work to fill the
time that's given for it
like it would be it would be phenomenal
i mean the the moon is going to slow the
earth's rotation
over the next couple of billion years
sufficiently that we're going to end up
with some really really long days
i didn't know that that's a good one but
you know so
so the but this gets pushed this
metaphor a bit more because
we kind of think that this longer life
is all the years come at the end of life
but it's not actually if in a way to
think about where these extremes have
come from they kind of come
late middle age it's like someone's
inserted kind of another 20 years at age
50.
and that then raises all sorts of issues
because as the day you know again
taking the day from 24 to 32 hours you
know
i i i would probably get out of bed
earlier
and go to bed later i'd have a lovely
sleep in the middle of the day
and i would probably not have three
meals i'd probably have five meals
hopefully smaller meals so i'd never
reach the sort of
hundreds um and i still call them
breakfast lunch and dinner but i'd shift
them and they would be different
and at different times and that's kind
of what's happening
with this life expectancy increase in
the 20th century we created teenagers
and pensioners they didn't used to exist
before the 20th century
so with life expensive gains we created
these two new stages of life
previously you just had children and
adults you didn't have teenagers
and of course as life is getting longer
i think you're also seeing major changes
in behavior so
people are now getting married at 30
rather than 20 they're having kids in
their 30s rather than 20s
again another kind of weird stat i think
last year in the uk for the first time
ever
um more women over 40 had a child than
women under 20.
no way which is a massive change
that's a huge huge difference and also i
you know
we've been talking about it a lot on
here evolution and the dating market and
the
um brutal evolution's brutal travesty
about
women is the the narrow window that they
have to to have
uh children in and that
stat that more women have children over
40 than under 20
is really you know that's great news for
a lot of women
absolutely but of course you're then
seeing all sorts of changes happen so
the other one
is on average the divorce rate is
falling in the uk
and i think that's because people are
getting married later they kind of know
themselves better and blah blah blah
um it's not to say you can't succeed if
you get married early but i it's sort of
you know
i think that's it and although the
divorce rate is falling on average
you're actually seeing the divorce rate
rise amongst the over 50s
and i think just doing some back of the
envelope calculations
it's probably growing fastest amongst
the over 80s
um so you know i can't think of a better
stat about longevity than divorces
rising in the 80s because uh you know
it's a kind of a sign of how long you've
been together and how much more time
there still is to go
you're seeing rises of stds amongst
people aged over 60 because you're
getting so much more dating happening in
this sort of remarrying market
um so these are kind of
deep changes in how we structure our
life and of course the younger you are
the bigger the implications and of
course one of them you said you know
work expands to the time available some
of those years you're gonna have to
spend working for longer
well yeah previously if you only had 15
years or 10 years
left after retiring you didn't really
need to be too concerned about
what the pot of gold was that you had
saved up in your in your icer or
whatever it was at the time
that's all going to change so
there's so much to get into i mean to
start to start with the
the new long life which is your book why
why did you feel like that needed to be
written just to kind of
open this door break the fourth wall to
people so they actually understand
what's going on
yeah so in 2016 we wrote the hundred
year life which was about
the this that you know the day going
goes to work from 24 to 32 hours and
what that means and we were sort of
saying
it changes careers it changes
relationships
change how you plan your life and then
what we were trying to do was put a
positive
narrative around aging and saying
actually the really good news is
you're living longer and you're
healthier for longer you've got more
time
and it's not at the end of life you can
use it across all of life
so it's like a liberating story one of
the feedback we got was oh great i'm
gonna have to work for long where the
job's gonna come from there's this tech
coming along
and you know that's gonna take over our
lives it's gonna make us all jobless
and i think again what's interesting is
these two phenomena of
aging and smart ai and robotics
i call it the frankenstein syndrome you
know there are
we're fearful of these great inventions
we've added years to life
we've got this wonderful new technology
coming along but we think it's going to
be a bad outcome
so the question is neither of them are
destiny we can shape them as we see
fit so how do you prepare for these
forces
what do you want to get out of them and
then how to make sure society achieves
that and i think
you know this to me is the key thing
where we are about to see some pretty
fundamental changes in life and work
and we've got to make sure it works for
us as people
and as a society so we need to start
saying i want this
and not that when the industrial
revolution first happened
you know you saw gdp improve you saw
this great new technology but it was a
pretty bad experience socially for lots
of people you know wages didn't rise
anxiety was high living conditions were
poor
and then after a while you started to
see trade unions a labor movement
and they said this is what we want from
it and so we then saw you know the
working week
go from six and a half days to six days
to
five days we've got the weekend we've
got bank holidays
uh we got all sorts of changes to make
sure that it could actually work for us
socially and that's kind of why we wrote
the new long life
we have these smart new technology these
longer lives
rather than be frightened by them how do
you make sure we actually seize the
advantages of them
are people going to be working until
they're 75 then and 80 is this realistic
well i think they will and they are i
mean uh it's quite staggering what's
already happening
um but yeah i mean we do some i do some
simple calculations in the hundred-year
life which sort of says
if you're gonna live to a hundred and
you're prepared to save
say ten percent uh a year of your income
which is pretty
ambitious and you want to retire and a
half of your final salary
you'll probably work into your late 70s
so
um yeah that's that's so then the
immediate thought is
wow god know how's that going to work
because if i start work at 20 and i
carry on doing the same thing to my
mid-seventies
that sounds pretty dull um
and you know are going to get bored uh
and also will i keep my job or
something happen so this is where we say
we're seeing a major shift and
you know your listeners i think will be
already aware of this i think it's
more of a shock to older people but the
three-stage life that was invented in
the 20th century of education
followed by a career followed by
retirement is already disappearing
retirement's kind of already gone
there's no point where everyone suddenly
stops working
and you're seeing more and more people
over 50 over 60 over 70 working
i think one in 10 brits over 70 are
working and that number number's just
rising
so we're seeing there but we're then
seeing changes right the way along
the career path because of course you do
things differently
and yeah for instance one of the things
we see is a lot of entrepreneurship
by people in their 70s and people in
their 20s and i think you can kind of
understand why because you know if we
have got this longer path
how do we use it to our advantage and i
think that gives us more time to
investigate and explore you certainly
don't want to commit
to her the options become more important
the longer the horizon you hold them for
so
again not marrying early perhaps is a
way of keeping your options open
discovering what you like and what
you're good at rather than rushing into
the first job
you know these are all possibilities
that we can try and experiment with
so that explains away the fact that i'm
still single at 32.
yes you're a young man thank you so
that's what you're saying andrew is that
actually it's
it's perhaps the most prudent approach
and not that i'm just hopeless
hopeless hopelessly single um yeah
it's so interesting to see the way that
people's relationships with their jobs
have changed right like you know we've
got
my core uh industry is nightlife so i
take students 18 and 19 year olds
these rough-hewn rocks and try and buff
them into brilliant
entrepreneurial gemstones over the
course of three years
and i see these kids we've got some of
the guys that work for us
who at 19 20 years old are
beasts absolute freak savages when it
comes to
being able to think laterally to problem
solve to
be able to deal with the chaos of being
in a nightlife environment for instance
and you think like um only in the gap of
14 years
between me at 32 and them at 18 19
i'm sick i wasn't anywhere near as
mature as that
and that's only in this time period
right so you're starting to see
young people being older and old people
being younger yes well i think that's
the i think that's kind of right
because you know that three-stage life
sort of age and stage come together but
in a multi-stage life you can kind of
and by modest life i mean you're gonna
have several different parts to your
career
and this is just about longevity let
alone things like technology coming into
play
but you're going to want to do different
things at different points in time it
may be this is time to focus on
relationships it may be a time to focus
on skills and learning
or making money or making a contribution
in society
and you're going to flip all those
around and that does require a certain
flexibility and i think actually that's
where
i mean particularly as you get older
it's going to be more important to sort
of
be young so adolescence is meant to be a
time of
change where it's kind of kind of scary
because
you're no longer the child you were but
you're not yet the adult you're
going to be and that's exciting because
i could be anyone but it's also
terrifying because who am i
and we have all these institutions to
help people through that but in a way
we're going to see that more and more at
every age because
you know you will find people in their
30s or their 50s or their 70s saying you
know what i'm going to i've got another
20 30 years ahead of me another 50 years
i would do something different
so how do you go through that process of
change and as a teenager we kind of
accept it but we now go try and accept
it at other stages and that's that's
tricky so
that in a way is a transition that kind
of binds lots of different people
together i'll tell you what i would
absolutely love i would love to see
someone in their 70s rocking up to do an
undergraduate degree
you know but they are doing it and so i
mean so this is a really good
point and you know i think we got a bit
messed up as a society about
age because we think so the the real
secret of age is we age very diversely
so so so if you accept that
chronological age is not a good measure
of biological age
you're going to age differently because
of bad luck
the environment that you live in and
because of your own diet behavior and
healthcare
so actually what happens as you get
older you see this great diversity in
how people age
you can be you know like colonel tom
moore and your hundreds raising millions
for charity or you could be in a
wheelchair at 50.
so actually older you get the less
relevant age as a number
is but we really just assume that
age tells you something and that
therefore everyone over 65
is the same now you wouldn't dream of
saying everyone under 35 is the same but
we kind of say it for the over 65s
but that three-stage life of education
work retirement
led to lots of age segregation you've
kind of lost this intergenerational
mixing and i think that's that's really
important so your idea of sort of people
in their 70s going back to university
it's actually happening amber places are
doing it uh of course it's got to be a
slightly different program with some
overlap but
we have lost a lot of that
intergenerational mixing which is why
we have all these dreadful stereotypes
around about
gen x baby boomers millennials which i
think really get in the way of just
seeing people as people
is that a byproduct of just the period
of change
that inevitably you do need to
categorize some people
into this is the
um this is the epoch of the world that
you lived through and this is the epoch
of the world that i lived through and
because of the pace of change
those epochs whereas previously might
have been 100 years or 50 years
and now like a 10-year gap so i think
you know
that's the theory and certainly um
you know they're a modern invention
these generational labels they didn't
used to exist
i i think there's something in them and
you're absolutely right that sort of
theory that
you know as the world changes this 10
years is different from that 10 years
but
but you kind of know that change doesn't
happen quite so discreetly
you know we can't point to that oh well
that's what caused that change
so that everyone's everything's a little
bit overlapping
and i think you know for me the trouble
with the generational stuff is not that
there isn't something there of course
there is uh you know a child who's
brought up
playing with an ipad from an early age
can be very different from one who
you know through whom you know the
telephone was uh something
uh to use so there's clearly gonna be a
difference but
of course what you see is technology
spread throughout society look at what's
happening in covert old people are using
technology a lot more
so it does spread through so i think the
the danger of the generation stuff is
twofold i
there's a whiff of um i call it
demographic astrology i don't know if
you like horoscopes
i don't but my my mum does so be careful
what you say you'll be getting you'll be
getting a message on instagram
people like them but the idea that your
character is firmly pinned down
by precise dates you were born in i
think can be
limiting and you know if i think of the
difference between the
average millennial and the average
baby boomer i think that's quite small
compared to the differences amongst
millennials
and amongst baby boomers so it's it's
too easy way of stereotyping i think
it's useful
about young and old and there are real
tensions there but i'm not quite sure
how much
insight we get from calling someone and
tell you why it worries me because it
becomes a zero-sum game
and why that's important is that you
know come back to some of the stats
again
uh a hundred years ago in 1920 when
spanish influenza happened
a 20 year old had a 50 chance of making
it to 70.
so most young people didn't become old
today it's 90 so basically
young people are gonna become old in a
way that they've never done before
and this is where some of the ages and
becomes a problem because it's kind of a
prejudice against your future self
uh and so you know i think you know when
you've got this
long life ahead of you you've got to
think about different stages in
different ways and
sadly the young aren't young forever
although if the scientists get the way
perhaps that will happen
um and i think we we forget that you
know this you know you're always a
millennial you're always a baby boomer
but
millennials are getting quite old now
they're you know they're middle aged
the the um you know it's the gen x are
now the younger ones or alpha gen or
whatever's coming through
and i think that's a better way of
looking at things than just saying
you're that group i'm this group there's
a constant conflict between us
i get it so a machine's going to take
our jobs you looked at
technology and technological change a
lot am i going to be replaced by a robot
on a microphone in a couple of years
time
uh yeah you might be um
so i i don't think so there's this smart
technology coming along
i i don't i mean depends how smart the
technology gets
there's in in the past technology is
what's made us richer it hasn't created
mass unemployment
it's created higher productivity higher
wages and a shorter working week and
let's hope that happens
it's pretty clear that ai is going to
change the jobs we do and it's going to
change how you do them
so even if you don't lose your job what
you do is going to change so
the way economists look at this is they
look at a job as being made up but lots
of different tasks so just bear with me
on this one so
a job may involve 20 or 30 tasks i'm a
economics professor i've got to do
research i've got to teach i've got a
grade and
i have to go to endless meetings so the
question is which of those tasks can be
automated
and if you look at what ai is doing the
first set of
tasks it started to get rid of what are
called
routine uh
kind of non-thinking tasks tasks that
you can just write a list of
processes and the machine can do it so
back office processing
check clearing that type of stuff now
what you're getting with technology is
it's starting to do two other things
it's starting to do
routine cognitive tasks so what's that
that's things like marketing legal
advice
accounting financial advice the sort of
the the standard stuff like give me a
bunch of numbers and tell me what's in
the marketing plan
give me a bunch of numbers and calculate
of an investment plan
that can all be done by ai and is
increasingly doing so
so all those tasks are starting to get
done the other set of tasks that is
happening is things like driverless cars
that are non-routine so it's
unpredictable
but sort of instinctive rather than
analytical and they're also disappearing
so it depends how much of your job is
made up of the task that can be
automated
and then how much that you're going to
shift into the avatar so i think in
terms of me as a professor we'll
probably get grading done by
robots and ai uh possibly teaching
done remotely but then i'll have more
meetings and more research
i'm sure it sounds like you're
absolutely thrilled about the idea of
more meetings
uh yeah exactly but uh so you know those
things that we as humans will always be
best at i think
the best way i think about what's going
to happen in the labor market is that
as machines become more machine-like
your advantage is in being more
human-like so what is it to be more
human
it's caring sharing empathy but also
sort of
decision making under uncertainty
ambiguity leadership those sorts of
things
so that's kind of where the jobs of the
future i think are
um not necessarily in the sort of
let me be ever smarter than the machine
but it does require
you know everyone's in a race with
technology for education keeps ahead of
technology you're doing okay
so we need to advance our education but
also it's going to require
different skills because i think most
people won't lose their job but what
their job is
will change so there's gonna be a lot of
upskilling and reskilling
required here if you were
someone now who is considering
re-skilling themselves how would you
make someone anti-fragile for the next
couple of decades in the job market
yeah and and you know so one temptation
of course is to uh
um get involved in coding and science
and there's lots of
jobs in the ai world for that the
evidence is just that that probably just
keeps your job for 10 years because soon
it becomes out of date and you need to
do something else
so i think the first thing is to accept
that probably
you know there's no job that's going to
be secure for 20 30 years
um so you may have to be continually
evolving and changing
um but one of the most important things
is just learning how to learn and to be
flexible
and also finding out what it is that you
like because if you're
going to be doing something for a long
while it's important that it's the right
thing for you so that experimentation
is also very very important but in
general
you know it's a combination of what we
call t-shaped learning it's going deep
in one dimension
and then broad in others and then every
now and then you'll have a you know your
career would change because you've gone
deep in a subject but
it'll need to evolve and shift into
something different so it is facing up
to the fact that probably every 10-15
years you're going to have to do a major
re-skilling or reorientation that's so
interesting
it's funny listening to how the rhetoric
that you're putting across
ties in with so much stuff that we've
touched on recently
dr adam hart who wrote unfit for purpose
which is an assessment of our
evolutionary heritage and how it's
misaligned with modern society
saying all the same things right we're
just gail golden curating your life
which is looking at how the work-life
balance is done
again it's all the same stuff and
we had peter c brown learning to learn
make it stick
creator we had him on this two years ago
if you haven't listened to that episode
go back and check it out it's awesome
um but yeah we had him on and he was
talking about that that the ultimate
ability
the ultimate anti-fragile skill is to
learn to learn it is
and that's so interesting so there's a
number of things that i won't pick up on
which is
really you know as you say fits in with
what i'm saying the first is that with
this
longer life one of the great skills is
going to be thinking long term
and that's not something we're hardwired
to do most of human existence has been
just surviving to the end of the day
little i'm planning you know 18 90 years
ahead
and that that that's going to be a
challenge i mean certainly uh
for me it is um but the other thing is
in thinking longer term
you've got to just rewind first of all
you mustn't kind of copy what your
parents do because your life will be
longer than theirs
but you've got to think about investing
in a range of i call it assets because
i'm an economist and some of that is
financial
but actually the most important thing is
going to see through this life will be
your skills your
relationships your health
and your sense of identity that can
navigate through these processes of
change
and that's gonna kind of be a great
opportunity because i think one of the
great things about living for a long
time is then it can be your life
you know it gets a bit buddhist like i'm
going to go through lots of stages what
is it that makes it all hang together
but that that sort of thinking long term
reinventing yourself and then
managing to staple it together is
important and you know this is where
the jobs are going to be very different
because the other thing that ai is going
to do not just
cause lots of changes to your career
but we're seeing jobs now sometimes you
have a job
where i go to a place of work and i have
an employer who pays me money
but we're increasingly seeing jobs also
being specified in terms of tasks in the
gig economy i have a task
and i get paid for that task and i don't
have an employer i just have somebody
pays me for that task
and over this long career you're going
to go through a whole bunch of cycles
where sometimes you've got a job
sometimes it's more task based
sometimes it's flexible work sometimes
it's
not contingent it's a proper job
sometimes you'll be working on site
sometimes you'll be working at home
so you're gonna be cycling through all
these different stages and sometimes
it'll be a choice
you know i i don't want that full-time
job i want to work in [ __ ] behind me
other times it's going to be [ __ ] i
really want a job but i'm stuck in the
gig economy
so it's going to be a lot of data i
think that leads to some big changes
because you mentioned work-life balance
don't get too historical here but i i
would has to guess that work-life
balance came in with industrial
revolution
because what industrial revolution did
was create a place of work and a place
of home
beforehand everything kind of happened
in the home or in the fields
and there wasn't a separation between a
place of work and a home
there wasn't a separation between work
and leisure
there probably wasn't much leisure and
it was all work but it was kind of
blended together
and then we get this work-life balance
how do i get my life at home and my work
done here but in this world of these
evolving jobs
work i think will take on a much broader
meaning because sometimes you'll be
doing work where you're not getting paid
for it
because you're brushing up on your
skills to get another job or i'm doing
some marketing hoping to get a job where
i'm networking i'm doing some charity
work
and it's a sense of productive use of
time but i'm not getting
a check for it and viewed like that i'm
not sure work life
balance even exists anymore it's kind of
just all blended into one
which many people are finding we covered
as a work from home anyway
but it's a very different way of
structuring a career and how you think
about things
from uh as i've got the fortune of being
able to ask an economist this
from a personal finances perspective
what is your view in this case on
managing wealth is the
most optimal approach as far as you're
concerned to
front load wealth acquisition to
downplay liabilities early in life and
then to be able to iterate on that
compounding effect as much as you can
or is it to live your life and then
because you've got long enough to
continue to earn as you get older
where do you sit on this spectrum so
because i
i kind of think of lots of things as
being an asset not just money
you're going to get compounding on
everything you're going to get
compounding on your health you're going
to get compounding on relationships
so it's really a question of balance i
think the financial one is
interesting because in this multi-stage
life you could spend the first 10 15
years not earning money
you know sort of washing your face
financially but that's just
you know that's just the aim of it and
then saying right i need money
or you could be working really hard to
get money to give you freedom
later i think in the end part of that is
going to be about you as a personality
about your attitude to risk and
you know i've got the money locked down
that's good
so it's really about thinking about how
your future then may unfold and you know
it could well be that's great getting
the money but of course you may be
missing opportunities which won't come
again
later so it's now a lot more complicated
i thought that's sort of
wimping out from the answer but any
investment advice has to be tailored for
the person
and i think it's totally legitimate not
to
focus on finances early on i think
actually
the really big value of this new stage
of life
is exploring not committing and normally
only large amounts of money involves
some form of commitment
but you know heck if it's if it bothers
you the money
um if you can get a job that you really
enjoy that brings in money
go for it but i think um
yeah uh and certainly compound interest
really helps
the the best advice i ever heard is
just to have a much your earning try and
put aside a fixed percentage into a
long-term pot
um and i think that's right even if it's
just up you know
five pounds a week or something like
that um it it really does make a
difference
um so that that would be the the best
advice but that's not about basing
everything around money
it's just making sure you have a pot
that is that long-term pot
i like it yeah it's uh it's interesting
to hear the explore exploit paradigm
come back out again it must be
it's like one in four guests talks about
interesting
talks about that um more more guests in
this year
than i can then i can name have come up
with that dynamic
so it's one of the ways in 109 i sort of
visualized things was it's like you're
playing a
computer game you've got these four uh
indicators
finances uh skills
um relationships and health
and then your ability to deal with
change and what you've got to make sure
is that
none of them are going in the red so
it's fine if you're focusing on money
right now as long as you think actually
when am i going to update my skills when
am i going to invest in my relationships
and so they're aware that there will
come a point where you have to flip
and similarly if you're just focusing on
skills like that's great you're building
up your skills but what about the other
things and
that's why i think life has got more
complicated because a life over 70 years
and a three-stage life all those things
were taken care of just by following
what everyone else did
that won't work anymore you have to do
things differently
it's it's interesting this this changing
dynamic
uh especially again having spoken to uh
professor adam hart about
our misalignment with our evolutionary
heritage who
who we are physiologically biologically
and what this environment is
doing to us um without the
old examples being set by the people
that are ahead of us
there's no you know i i lead such an
incredibly different life from my
parents
so unbelievably different from when they
were at my age and also from when i will
be at their age so it's like when do you
when do you learn right there's no one
here teaching us
accruing this wisdom you know there
isn't there isn't
and that's both you know like so it's
called liminality that sense of sort of
you know in betweenness
where you're neither you know betwixt
them between of course it can be
exciting because like i can you know i
don't have to do everyone else did
but i think for that the other thing you
need to do is to look around you and see
what others
are doing and and how they're
experimenting and going oh that looks
interesting
i mean it was as part of the hundred
life i still started reading up about
how we invented teenagers
and it's kind of just fun how we
invented teenagers
uh you know for most of human history
you became went from a child to being an
adult
and it occurred sometime between 12 and
14.
and then suddenly with industrial
revolution we extend
schooling uh and suddenly you know
people at school to 14 16 and now
18 and it's like [ __ ] what do we do with
these young adults without
responsibility
and it took about 60 years to work it
out it's so interesting
so you know that the first sort of stuff
was things like
uh the bobby soxes and the stuff oh no
the first thing was like the boy scouts
and the boys brigade it was
stick them in uniform give them some
discipline and you know that that's what
you do children little children army
yeah
yeah then it was uh the the bobby soxes
which is sort of you know
uh it's being middle-aged when you're
young and then kind of james dean comes
along he's like
that's it that's what teenage years are
uh so it took
40 50 years for society to work out how
to use
that time and now of course we all know
what teenagers are we know what they do
it's kind of a rite of passage
but we're seeing the same thing i think
in people's 20s
i think we're also seeing same thing in
people's 50s where
um you should be called a midlife crisis
but now i think it's called something
different
and also people in the 70s behaving very
very very differently i mean
i at the you know the average age of the
rolling stones i know this is a good or
a bad example
it's like mid-seventies or something uh
and so that's called paul mccartney paul
mccartney turned like 72 the other day
didn't you yeah
yeah i think that's right yeah yeah but
then of course you see other things like
i think how old is prince charles is
he's 71. i don't
like whatever they're doing to them
they're some nad booster director
david sinclair but um yeah no the
davidson cluster but
you know but he's 71 and he still hasn't
got the job that's the interesting thing
how long am i supposed to wait for this
thing it's going to be the oldest
monitor if it comes to the train to be
the oldest sonic ever to come to the
throne
well i mean a perfect example of this as
well let's look at the um
presidential candidates yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
everyone's getting older and people say
i mean the criticisms about biden seem
to actually hold
hold true but people are saying like how
can you have
they compare them to jfk right who's
this sort of young
vibrant guy and you think well
yeah but in this new frontier
it's actually like is 70 70 is like
what like maybe 55 or 60 now and
40 back then is probably closer to like
55 now
it's everything because jfk was not as
long as you think and actually
pretty poor health which is also quite
interesting but uh
yeah he had all sorts of health elements
but i think this is where the sort of
the generational labels come in because
you know we've got to try and find a way
as life gets longer to get
different voices being heard in all
sorts of ways i mean this
is key for all of society and you know
if
our leaders get older and older how do
then younger people get their voice
heard and i think that is a challenge
comes back again to these
intergenerational vehicles we have to
create
yeah uh speaking of dr david sinclair
who i'll send this to once we're done
uh he was on the podcast a year and a
bit ago and he was talking about how
um he believes that at some point in the
not too distant future
humans very well may be able to live to
a thousand i don't listen
i'm sat in harvard medical school uh
looking at him and thinking like yeah
that sounds great but that's like
you know that's proper science fiction
stuff that's that's forever away
but we are that will be a spectrum
someone's not going to one day just be a
thousand
someone will be 150 then there'll be 200
then there'll be 250 then
um like we are seeing this
happen in front of us right now we are
seeing people get
older the entire demographic of the
world is getting older
and i read this story the other day i
don't know whether you've seen this in
the washington post
about this 40 million
asian men who are una they can't get
married
yeah yeah so you've got this um
population
the birth rate is now starting to level
out it looks like maybe about
10 10 million 11 million or something is
where the world's going to kind of even
out at
and then potentially even take a dip so
that's going to push the average age
even
further up it is and i know david well
in fact i'm writing with david so i
and you know i look at the how society
adapts to longer lives that already
happened
and you know so to me the big insight is
that to a degree we've
didn't expect we found that age is
malleable there are things we can do
that affect how we age
and david in this extraordinary
scientific way says yeah just wait i'm
going to fiddle about and it's
really going to be malleable um now i i
do
i never know what to make of those
claims it's pretty clear that what is
happening is an interesting shift um
as we get older uh chronic diseases get
more important
cancer dementia heart disease and if
you've got all of these
they're all correlated strongly with age
the biggest risk factor in getting
cancer is age not smoking
not the smoking is a good thing but you
know it's uh so
what a bunch of people are saying is
well let's focus on slowing down
aging which is a staggering thought but
you're already sort of seeing quite
advanced drugs that hold the promise of
getting rid of arthritis
so you will start to see more older
people but they'll be behaving
differently and you know that we said
earlier that 70 is the new 60s not
really 70 is the new 70
because you can you may have the health
of a 60 year old but you've got
10 more years of road under the uh on
the clock
so it's kind of a really different
combination so i think that's
interesting
but i think it's important to
disentangle two things one is the change
in the age structure of society which is
there's more old people because there's
fewer people being born
and in asia that's really dramatic i
mean it is extraordinary what is
happening in asia
the chinese population is going to go
from 1.4 to 1 billion
over the next 30 years there'll just be
400 million people left
and of that 1 billion 45
will be over 65. is this all because of
this
single child policy so i mean it's
basically because
when you grow very fast your birth rate
falls very quickly
and so you get smaller cohorts coming
through and then more people living
longer
actually the us and the uk and europe
that's much less because the birth
rate's fallen much more slowly over time
so we're aging less but the other thing
is not just there's more old people but
how our aging is changing
and this is why i'm so glad to be
talking to you and and your younger
group because
actually that's the group are going to
be most affected by this
and the challenge we've got is that if i
when i say to people how long
you're going to live for um how many of
you even thought about it most people
haven't and i get that it's kind of not
a pleasant thought
and then about a third of people stick
their hand up in the class when i asked
this and i said okay so what what
information did you use and also their
grandparents
now if you look at the data and it's a
big argument whether it's going to carry
on
or not over the last 100 years in every
decade
life experience has gone up by two or
three
which basically means that every
generation is living six to nine years
longer than their parents
and 12 to 18 years longer than their
grandparents so if you
base yourself on your grandparents if
that trend continues you're out by 18
years
so wow and then it's like great it comes
back that the day going from 24 to 32
hours long don't just use it all at the
end of life you can use it right the way
through
and you need to do that because
otherwise if you try and just copy that
life that your parents had
you're going to be working until 75 76
which is
gruesome in one single block so
you know to me you know time is a social
convention
we structure it in a way to make it work
for us
and what's interesting right now is it's
kind of our structured life isn't
working for anyone the younger
generation are saying
you know i can't get all the things that
past generations did i can't afford a
house i won't get a pension i would
never secure a job
absolutely they need to do things
differently but actually it's not
working for people in their 50s because
they're now trying to work to their 70
and there's so much age-based
stereotypes they can't get jobs
and then you need to look at covert and
the disaster that's unfolded in care
homes
to recognize that we don't have a way of
looking after people in the end of life
so
at all ages we've got to try and
come up with what laura karstenstein
stanford calls a new map of life
it's particularly urgent the younger you
are would you say which is great to be
talking about this but
to focus on we focus on aging is about
the old but really if it's a longer life
it's for everyone it's about all of life
not end of life
so who does the burden of this lie with
because it seems to me
to be an economic problem both
locally and globally it seems to be
a sort of a social action problem or
social reform problem
that needs to occur top down but then
there's also this
emergent self-identifying um
the social norms that we have like how
do we identify not what are we told
about age
because you can tell someone whatever
you want it takes a very long time
for them to internalize that and then
begin to bleed that back out of them and
and also agree with everyone else right
so yeah who where does the book stop
with this or where does it start
actually where does the book
start with this so it's absolutely so
the new long life the latest book which
looks at technology and
longevity entwined so it says how do you
prepare
and i'm afraid there is a lot that you
need to do in a period of social change
because well the other thing that's
happening
rightly or wrongly is a lot more
responsibilities being thrown on the
individual
so you know for instance if you've got
this multi-stage life where some of it's
in the gig economy
you're now taking responsibility for
learning the skills and your career
in a way that a firm would do if you
work for them health is incredibly
important and you know i think there's
more awareness and
younger groups about the importance of
investing your health and keeping fit
for the future
but again as an example at
responsibility so there's lots of things
that the individual has to do but then
my goodness there's a bigger social
narrative and some of that is around
changing our concepts for instance
around age which i think is happening
with covert i think it's very
interesting
because covert is like a viral attack of
aging it's really impacting older people
but we're starting to see a narrative
emerge about what it means to be old is
it just a number of years candles on the
cake etc
um there's things that the education
system needs to do we have an
educational system
very much based around the first 21 24
years of life
it needs to focus on lifelong learning
corporates need to think about things
very differently rather than just get
obsessed about the graduate intake
then after that's thing about recruiting
majorly in the early 30s and mid 40s
right the way through multiple career
points and have a career path where you
can ramp up and ramp down
rather than just slog your way through
governments have a lot to do here as
well because you know i talked about
aging
technology worries me because you'd be
saying about will jobs be lost or not
they don't have to be and i think what's
really interesting about technology is
we use the word technological
progress but i think we should use the
word technological achievement
because there's only really progress if
we make it work for us as
humans and particularly around jobs
firms
can either use technology to automate
and to get rid of workers
and save costs or they can use
technology to augment workers
to improve what they do the quality of
the work the quality of the product and
productivity and so wages
why would they do that from a businesses
perspective because they make more money
they make more money by including by
remaining keeping workers there how
well so let's give the example of uh
health
or education actually so what we're
finding more and more is of course
um you can learn stuff on the internet
you can have a robot that does
tests for you you can learn loads of
stuff so you can get rid of lots of
teachers you can do robots that
eventually get better and better at
diagnostics
and we'll be able to allo tell you about
what your health is
so we could get rid of lots of health
workers but what will be even better
would be to have a health worker or an
education worker
who sees you chris as a person and says
okay i can see you're struggling in this
issue or you're doing really well here
let's think about how we get better how
do we improve it
so then what you're doing is freeing the
teacher away from the mundane routine
stuff which is
just conveying the information and
focusing on the individual and saying
how do i get this individual
to do better so i go to the gym when i'm
allowed to go to the gym i am
i have an instructor quite an instructor
it's not i don't know how to use the
machines
it's not i don't know how to do a
push-up they're just going to motivate
me to do the things i don't want to do
and to do the things i do badly better
so that would be an example
and you know what worries me
particularly post covert is that firms
will just use technology to cut
costs and i'll be stuck on a phone to
some pretty [ __ ] piece of technology
that's very frustrating doesn't provide
me a good service
and has made someone lose a job so there
must be an
incentive that the government can
provide through the tax system
so for instance in america and i think
it's probably the same from the uk
there's lots of
incentives for firms to invest in
capital equipment because they get a
write-off
so let me invest all the ai i get a
capital write-off
it's like a tax advantage for automation
we need to provide incentives to do
augmentation
because that's how we prosper and that's
that first stage industrial revolution
there was lots of automation
the second stage of industrial
revolution was much more augmentation
so this comes back again to starting a
social narrative
what do we want from this and there's a
dystopian route to go
and there's a utopian route
but unless we start a social narrative
and it takes a long while
but in particular i think especially
around technology and i think longevity
as well
it's really important that it's us as a
society that say how we want this
technology to go
and not google and facebook and right
now that's the problem the incentives
about what ai
is produced is not really aimed to think
at
technological progress in a social sense
but more around technological
achievement and a profit motive as well
so
i think it's quite urgent we start
thinking about you know if we have an
opportunity to be more
human as machines become more
machine-like
how do we seize that um i think it's
karpov said that ai
won't change on human nature it will
just reveal it
i think that's a good way of looking at
it actually
we're not very good at being machines
that's that's why calculating numbers is
difficult
machines are great at that we're good at
being humans yeah you are correct
it's um it's interesting i think it was
cal newport's book deep work
where i was reminded or i was first
told what it is that we do in the
workplace that we're complex decision
engines
that's what we're able to do and it
would appear based on who you look at
from the artificial general intelligence
insight community um it would appear
that
proper broad spectrum agi
is actually moving very slowly that
narrow general intelligence is getting
very very good
but the the ability to
compile and synthesize all of these
different pieces of information
is still where the competitive advantage
for the very foreseeable future is going
to lie for humans is that something you
agree with
yeah absolutely i mean there's a whole
bunch of issues here so there's
you know what tasks you do in your job
which gives you some defense there's
regulation may defend you but then
there's that one about you know we're
still some way off the singularity if
ever it's going to happen
um so completely agree and then
you know certainly you know deep
knowledge has shown us that there's some
fantastic
things that ai can do it's pretty
expensive in doing it
so it's only when it becomes cheap it
also starts to rival
but there should be i mean i think this
is the trouble with technology is that
the technologists i think four for two
problems and economists have
problems of their own but the
technologists
they exaggerate how fast the technology
is coming
um you know driverless cars that come
along with leaps and bounds but still
most the cars on the road are not
driverless
and in some way before they will and
that's not about the technology that's
about just implementation
the second thing is they see the jobs
that will be destroyed
but they don't see the jobs that will be
created and if you go back to the
industrial revolution
hundreds of thousands of jobs were
destroyed you know the farming jobs were
destroyed
um but we invented a whole bunch of jobs
that no one could have
predicted some of those jobs were about
supporting the machines
but actually most of them like the
managerial roles etc
just were just didn't exist before and
you know the same thing will happen this
time around
there will be whole new jobs created
some of them aimed at supporting the ai
and the technology but in general
there'll be a lot of jobs that will be
very human
orientated exploiting that comparative
advantage that humans have
um all this of course is not destiny we
can't just leave it to the markets we
have to have the right
education system the right government
policies but yeah that that
hopefully is what we will see it's
interesting uh rory sutherland pastor
modern wisdom guest and
fantastic behavioral psychologist he uh
he talks about how he thinks silicon
valley sees everything as an
optimization problem
and that sort of hyper technocratic
view of the world fails to take into
account
that the people who at the very end are
going to judge whether a thing was good
or bad
are not input process output perfect
rational
machines right so you can have something
which by every objective measure was
great
but it did the thing that it was
supposed to do um
the machine which is going to be your
new comedian
right the machine can tell a joke which
logically rationally deliverably is
funnier than any joke that's ever been
told but there's something that we just
don't quite get about the fact that we
don't like that
and it's irrational but that is
something which is difficult to program
for
yeah no it's 100 uh and you know that's
a nice
bulwark and by the way you know it's a
great advantages to come
my worry is that if certain groups
become
incredibly important then they will
drive the direction of ai research
in a route that maybe that we don't like
it but it's the way it's going because
it's easy and it's
where the power is right the
disproportionate amount of power yeah
so what is it we kind of touched on it
there like is it
is it legislation because it's all well
and good me and you
and david dr dr sinclair saying uh
we need to think more about aging we
need to think very carefully about how
jobs are being replaced
but like who are we who am i
to to enact this change that's signing
it what would you
sign a petition at change.org and get
someone to read it and throw it away
well i think this this comes back so
that
you know i i do think it is about
raising awareness from raising a
narrative and experimentation and people
saying this is what i want i'm not
getting it and then
making sure that gap is closed um
if you go back to industrial revolution
which i i you know still tailor so much
of our life
you did see is only with the spreading
of democracy and the rise of the labour
movement
and civil society and charities a
campaigning
attitude that led to change
and i think it has to be the same again
i think the interesting thing is where
is that going to come from because
with industrial evolution the concept of
you know the working class was much
larger and more homogenous
and that doesn't seem to exist so much
now
not in that sort of large single issue
way
um so it has to be civil society and i
think this is where we are in a
difficult situation because
for a society to be healthy just two
pretty simple things have to happen
the first is everyone has to feel that
in some way
they're benefiting from the economic
achievements and growth that's happening
and now there is in some way they have
to feel that they've got a voice
that is listened to and reflected in the
outcome
and if you have those two together
societies tend to prosper economically
and
socially so that's what we have to
achieve that's why we need a narrative
we need to start thinking about this
because
everyone's aware that the old ways
aren't working so what do we want to
replace it with
um but we do seem to in that interim
period at the moment where we've got
more people looking back
either trying to preserve the system or
complain about it rather than advocating
something going forward
and i think that's inevitable because
you know we said it's we don't know what
works we don't know what's going to
happen
but i think we do need to start having
that as a social
debate um but this i think is where the
ai staff can become dangerous because
the ai
just generates jobs for a certain type
of people
and if you know we get ai which ends up
with certain groups of people being
excluded from the political process or
political process not working so well
then we end up into some very
uncomfortable conjectures about the
future
where we've got lots of social divisions
we've got people being excluded from the
political process
and that never ends well so i think you
know that that's why to me how to make
this happen
it's civil society it's a social debate
that then says i want this and i'm
hoping
and covert will see something that lasts
because
i do think in covert we've learnt that
we cannot rely upon
firms and we can't always arrive on the
government even though they have a big
role to play
and in the end we have to rely upon each
other and those around us
even those who perhaps we haven't spent
much time with are late
and i think that's that's a healthy sign
going forward if we can carry on with
that
i mentioned this at the beginning of
kovid that i felt as tragic as it is
if one thing can come out of it it
unites us in our humanity right it's
it doesn't even rain everywhere on the
planet at the same time but i know what
it feels like to be in lockdown the same
as someone in wuhan the same as someone
in texas the same as someone in south
america
and like i'm reading the precipice
by toby ord at the moment which is on
existential risk it's a very good
meta-analysis of all different types of
existentialists
phenomenal for you would you would adore
it it's brand new
uh he also is part of this future of
humanities institute at oxford
university
who are literally impossible to get a
hold of
which means that to the listeners if
you're hoping i'm going to get toby on
him
it's not happening apparently because
he's just impossible to to find
um but like speaking
listening to what he's talking about
there
in one way it doesn't surprise me that
having people that are separated by
nation states and borders and have
cultures and all this sorts of stuff and
we've got all this crazy evolutionary
heritage and we're tribal and we're
basically just shaving apes that have
somehow are able to impact our own will
and all this sort of stuff
i think oh god like how are we even able
to step out onto the street without
ripping each other to shreds
but on the flip side of that i think
let's say that humanity does level out
about 10 billion 11 billion people like
it shouldn't be
that hard to get one species
that's got more than enough spec tons
tons of space tons of resources
bags of technology even more time to
accrue wisdom
now and increasingly more time for
individuals
to iterate on making themselves better
making society better
like it shouldn't be that hard it should
just be you should be able to do it and
get humanity to work
well that's kind of what we're saying in
the new york life i mean my my thought
the new life at the beginning is
you know we've got we've shown this
great technological ingenuity in making
lives longer and healthier
and inventing this extraordinary new
technology so we should be smart enough
to have the social ingenuity to make it
work for us and you know what is
interesting i think about
humans is actually just to some extent
our success is based around
a deep trust of people we never meet so
you know when i'm sitting on a plane
i'm putting my life in the hands of
people i just don't know
and will never meet again possibly
everything from the pilot to the person
who's checking the engines and
i trust these people and that's quite
extraordinary that deep seated
interpersonal trust now
of course when society starts to become
fractured and this group are excluded
then that trust starts to disappear
but i i do think ultimately you know
there is a deep-seated sense of trust in
humans and that has to be what we
uh that we rely upon so yeah that we
should be
i mean we're we've got a pretty good
track record of making things work for
us
uh let's just hope we carry on doing
that yeah absolutely well we haven't not
made it work yet
but obviously as someone like toby says
that's that's the problem that as we
keep on not making it work there's a
greater chance of us managing to do it
the other way so
this has been uh it's been fantastic
thank you so much for your time andrew
uh the new long life will be linked in
the show notes below anything else that
you want to plug any other places people
should go to check out stuff that you
think is interesting
there's a website uh for the book and
then there's my own website as well
which we'll give you a link to but uh
yeah start with the book and
start the narrative and start thinking i
love it thank you so much for your time
thanks chris it's been a blast thank you
[Music]